happy
Wednesday so yeah all
right I know I know yeah it's what it's
like to be loved
Jamie so scientists just confirmed there
are three man-made things that can be
seen from outer space the Panama Canal
the Great Wall of China and
Tyrus just kidding about the last one
it's actually the Towering stupidity of
the Colorado Supreme
Court that's thank you I'll take it it
makes Pike's Peak look as flat as Joe
Biden's
EKG and a 4 to3 decision four Democrat
appointed judges from the ivy league
just voted to remove Trump's name from
next year's presidential ballot in other
words they just endorsed him they just
did more for his chances of becoming
president than Joe and commas
incompetence put together and that's
saying something are these four judges
the only people alive who haven't
noticed that every time the Dems use the
Constitution as a snot rag Trump's
numbers rise faster than Hunter's heart
rate after an
eightball maybe maybe they really want
Sher to move to
Canada yeah insult him impeach him Indi
him it doesn't matter he's like one of
those strangulation knots that gets
tighter the more you pull against it
Trump's a Chinese finger
cuff that toy used on unsuspecting kids
that traps their fingers in a small
bamboo cylinder it's how I steal their
shoes and with Biden polling lower than
Hamas the Dems are freaking out which
means time to do something
unconstitutional and illegally spying on
us campaign is oh so 2016 so now in a
private club in Denver four judges are
toasting each other for election
interference they're looking all them
nodding like bobbleheads during an
earthquake champagne quirks are popping
vegan or derves are being passed Liz
Cheney and Rob Riner are calling them to
thank him for saving democracy Adam
kininger is crying tears of joy and the
view have already eaten themselves into
a
coma but you know what it all means that
Republicans may have the biggest laugh
yet since they saw Obama riding a
bike so what is it about Trump the man
is a giant orange syringe a truth serum
shoved into the collective ass of our
body
politic he's the Great revealer
mentioned his name and the power hungry
elit start howling like Joy bear at a
full
moon it's as if they're showing you who
they really are like Lori Lightfoot
after covid the mask is off and it's
terrifying in an act of Mile High virtue
signaling these judges decided that
never mind facts Trump must be removed
because of his support of
Insurrection Trump has four pending
criminal cases and the same amount of
charges for Insurrection as I do which
is none never mind that he hasn't even
been tried yet even special prosecutor
Jack Smith who's about as unhinged as
Maxine Waters
wig could only make up election
interference charges even that's a
bigger stretch than when Dana Perino
reaches a door handle so did these
judges never hear of that innocent until
proven guilty thing these robed Rubes
were so concerned they actually added a
provision barring him from being a
right-in candidate in fact in Colorado
now you're not even allowed to think
about Donald Trump and if you do they'll
make you live in
Denver so now that it's reached magical
thinking status we're about to find out
who everybody really is if you're in
government we're about to hit you with
the Constitutional sodium pentol forget
the Dems we know what they're going to
say we have to protect democracy by SP
buying censoring arresting and banning
the opposition the worst Trump ever did
was block someone on Twitter until a
court said that violated free speech but
every Republican candidate now is to
show how much they believe in due
process and basic constitutional
principles isn't that right Cookie
Monster they have to stand against this
kudos to vake he's already stated he
won't be on the ballot if Donald Trump
isn't but the left would hatch a
40-year-old charge against VI but back
then he'd only be Nega
-2 but at the next debate any Republican
who takes anything but an unequivocal
stance against this should be given a
one-way ticket to presidential candidate
Oblivion otherwise known as Mitt Romney
Airlines and since this is an
unprecedented use of the 14th Amendment
you know who else is on notice the
Supreme Court themselves yeah you can
only hide your feelings about the
founding fathers under those robes for
so long they're supposed to be our best
and brightest legal minds and yet one of
them isn't even sure what a woman is so
we're watching scotus and that means you
John Roberts they only invertebrate with
a comb
over they need to remember our system is
based on precedent remember when Harry
Reid changed the filibuster rule that
precedent allowed Republicans to
filibuster meric Garland allowing Trump
to gain a Scot's majority that blew up
their in their mugs so badly nany's face
is still
recovering talk about being hoisted on
your own patard it's happening so often
to them they're mentally
petarded anyway if this blatant voter
cancellation stands then Republicans can
do the same Trump not qualifying in
Colorado could easily be Biden not
qualifying in Florida is that what we
really want judges deciding our
elections I have one word to say to that
Janine
yeah what's going
on she wants the death penalty for
leaving the toilet seat
up so maybe these four judges had a bout
of altitude sickness or hit one of the
many legal dispensaries before they
voted but this decision has got to be
the thinnest thing to come out of
Colorado since core's light and what's
amazing is all four of them pass the bar
and they sit in Judgment of others
that'll keep you up at night worse than
a shortage of flow
[Laughter]
so thankfully much like Joe without his
rubber sold shoes this almost certainly
won't
stand but what's sad and amazing is if
Donald Trump had not swung the Supreme
Court it could have that's tragic and
scary because as the Colorado Supreme
Court accuses Trump of insurrection and
election interference today's Democratic
party should hold that thought you
opened a Pandora's Box that would make
the unibomber sue you for
plagiarism perod let's welcome tonight's
guests unlike Santa he doesn't get to
see his kids for Christmas actor writer
and comedian Jamie
[Music]
lissow she's as committed to reporting
as Hunter is to snorting former NFL
sideline reporter Michelle Tafoya
on Christmas night Santa leaves out food
for her New York Times bestselling
author and foxus contributor cat
Tim and he uses the Seattle Space Needle
to remove splinters New York Times
bestselling author comedian and former
NWA World T
Champion Jamie does Colorado take taking
Trump away from the ballot remind you of
your ex-wife taking everything you owned
and loved away from
you uh only the only difference is that
the Trump thing is going to get
reversed
um good but yeah a little bit um I I
would I don't know if anybody else was
surprised once they get past like 10
Amendments I'm like yeah I don't know
what they
say like the the 14th one was like if
you incite an Insurrection just seems
kind of convenient that they apply this
to the office of the presidency and then
I guess Biden heard what happened he was
like Insurrection I can't get one of
those without a double dose of
Viagra yeah I'm so his approval ratings
are they're very low did you see today
it was they were passed by brussels
sprouts and Bud
Light have high I haven't seen an abuse
of power like this Greg since I paid
that hooker to tie me up and she took my
wallet it's so unfair yeah I'm sorry
about that you know uh Michelle I love
the media response to this I mean either
they're lying to themselves I was
watching something and Mary Trump was
like it she was having like the worst
orgasm of her life or that's how her
face always
is but they know that this is this is
not going to stand it's unconstitutional
other states reject it it's hilarious it
is hilarious and they are there's like
this cheering section and it's led by
Rachel mattow um you know what I'm to
read one of the dissenting judges
Justice Carlos samore Jr wrote and I'm
sorry I have to put on glasses because
I'm just that blind he wrote even if we
are convinced that a candidate committed
horrible acts in the past dare I say
engaged in Insurrection there must be
procedural due process before we can
declare that individual disqualified
from holding public office so three of
these judges know yeah that this is not
going anywhere I I had the feeling
instantly this Court in Colorado wants
to be known for something exactly they
want to be the activist judges that did
this and look at us and we're going to
be on the map now and everyone's going
to remember us so true but it is going
to get overturned by the Supreme Court
and you're right the only way to make
this truly truly convincing to everybody
if it's a 90 decision it's got to be
like unanimous otherwise as you said
everyone's going to tell us exactly who
they are yeah and it's funny uh the
judges that that voted for this are all
ivy league and the judges that don't
were I think from Denver University of
Denver they do have a university in
Denver I believe I'm not sure if it's
real cat this just cements Trump as
America's bad boy you know he's like
that guy that your parents tell you not
to date and the more they tell you not
to date him the more irresist sounds
personal for you
yeah I was just using a well-worn cliche
okay uh isn't it true though Trum
doesn't have to do any work there's one
thing he hates it's talking about how
the system's against
him it's his favorite thing to talk
about Trump talking about the system
being against him that's like his
Canadian boob teacher
right he'll bring it up and he can talk
about it and also it's just the argument
on the other side you don't have to like
Trump at all to see how absurd it is to
say we need to save democracy and we're
going to save democracy by not allowing
you to vote for this person that you
want to vote for which I thought was
like the whole thing with democracy but
maybe I'm an idiot right it's it's so
there's no way it goes through if
anything it does make him more popular
and it does make it just adds another
thing where he can say when he does
those rallies where he just
extemporaneously speaks it seems and
he'll have another thing yeah it's true
oh Colorado blah blah blah no he's just
added more minutes to his set yeah you
no it's true they they are electing him
Tyrus because if you were on the fence
about Trump you realize you have to
support him now because this is this is
they're trying to take your choice away
from you even if you weren't going to
vote for him well they're trying to take
you away from you yeah because if you
don't fall in line you could go away too
just the difference is President Trump
has a huge War chest of money to be able
to defend himself if he didn't he'd be
sitting in court but the bigger the
scarier thing is is and we we talk about
all the time so they're using their
powers as judges for their personal mhm
motivations which in any other situation
they should be not judges anymore
because here's the thing they're not
they know damn right well what the
reason why they're doing it is a timing
thing yes the Supreme Court will
overturn it but when M and what's going
to happen during that time there'll be
all kinds of leftwing people because
they're a lot Bolder than the the right
you know all the they'll go to their
homes they'll go to their family homes
they'll the judge will be sequestered
they can't can't come in they don't want
to then the judges themselves the whole
system might be like well let's wait
till it's you know this whole thing
blows over before we do and the meia is
going to ramp it up so in a perfect
world he can't get on the the ballot and
then this the Supreme Court sees it
after the election they win and they get
five more states to do this knowing
perfectly well it's not going to last
but it's for them this whole thing has
been a a it's the long game for the left
the extreme left this they progressives
it's not a short game they know exactly
what they're doing yeah it's going to be
overturned but when I think it might be
Dana says that's Dana Pino I go I I get
to call her Dana she says it could
happened before Christmas because it's
so absurd but you your point is well
taken they're going to try to slow walk
this like they do with Joe um but you
know what the more they orchestrate this
stuff against Trump the more you look
back at 2020 and you go that was
orchestrating they told you they
literally they're worse than every bad
guy in every be movie ever made they
literally tell you exactly what they're
doing they just put Trump in front of it
that's all they do it's true they do the
speech they do the you just don't get it
Scott yeah like you just don't get it
before I kill you I will talk to you
while you untie yourself the person is
always untying themselves while the
villain is telling him what he's going
to do I said left leaning sharks with
freaking laser beads it's not that hard
all right up next plagiarism allegation
stack against an academic
[Applause]
hack Gutfeld holiday
memories there was one Christmas when
Greg finally agreed to stop making jokes
about my hair it was the best 1,200
bucks I ever
spent Gutfeld holiday
memories hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else